nous avons besoin de nous rencontrer
mais encore davantage de tout faire pour
comprendre de n'écarter rien du débat et
de la réflexion de réfléchir ensemble
dans notre travail
il n'y aura aucun tabou il y aura des
choses désagréables
il faut les aborder il faut apprendre de
l'échec c'est les échecs qui ne
construisent il faut tenir compte
absolument des bouleversements
fantastique qui vont se prévoir il faut
transposer le gaullisme dans cette
mutation
[Musique]
la vérité est toujours moins violente
que le tennis à ce qui nous marque d'un
point de vue général c'est l'affirmation
de ce que vous êtes et à la valeur
travail
le rapport aux mérites la notion de
liberté le rapport à la responsabilité
le rapport à la famille à la sécurité à
l'éducation à la justice des valeurs
clairement de droite pas de confusion
droite gauche parce que ça vous tue
parce que ça crée du trouble et vous en
remettez pas dix ans car la ligne
politique que nous devons essayer de
construire de tenir c'est celle d'une
droite qui assume ses convictions ses
droits tout soit ouverte
mais en même temps qu'ils assument tous
ses engagements mais c'est surtout de
les traduire en acte concret
[Musique]
vous faites des retraités des classes
moyennes des familles et des
collectivités locales
les principales victimes de votre budget
pourquoi s'en prendre aussi aux
épargnants vous gâcher la croissance
vous réduisez l'effort de maîtrise des
dépenses publiques des ti responsables
voire dangereux de sortir d'état
d'urgence dans l'intérêt national vous
n'avez en réalité aucune ambition pour
nos territoires ruraux qui apporte tant
à la france nous sommes les
représentants de la france de la
proximité de la france du concret de la
vie quotidienne des français
[Musique]